ulrich et tel aviv l'attentât apparaît
probable même hypothèse en ce qui
concerne l'explosion qui s'est produite
à bord de la caravelle francfort vienne
en israël l'attentât n'a fait aucun
doute dès les premiers instants la
revendication plein de vantardise de cet
acte par une organisation terroriste
arabe est une nouvelle illustration du
caractère et début meurtrier de ces
groupes a déclaré le premier ministre
israélien madame gold amer le conseil
des ministres israélien s'est réuni ce
matin tel aviv et a défini une première
politique de riposte israël considère
comme responsable des attentats non
seulement les organisations terroristes
mais également les pays qui leur donne
asile israël adressera sans doute un
appel à tous les pays ainsi qu'aux
organisations de l'aviation civile leur
demandant de prendre d'énergiques
mesures contre ceux qui accordent
protection aux terroristes de leur côté
les organisations de libération
palestinienne démentent toute
participation à l'attentât
quoi qu'il en soit et devant la menace
qui pèse sur leur passage et leurs
équipages et leurs appareils plusieurs
compagnies ont vivement réagi dès hier
l'abbé à la british européenne airways a
décidé de suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre
les vols de ses avions de ses
avions-cargo s'agit donc de fret à
destination d'israël même décision de la
part de la compagnie autrichienne
propriétaire de la caravelle francfort
vienne qui a heureusement pu se poser
après l'explosion d'une charge
dissimulés dans un paquet à destination
d'israël
une décision dans le même sens a été
prise à la bo assez à copenhague la sas
annulé aujourd'hui son vol copenhague
tel-aviv il s'agit d'un vol hebdomadaire
il faut donc pas en tirer de conclusions
pour la semaine à venir
et c'est ainsi que quelques 120
passagers ont été acheminés en israël
par des itinéraires des tournées à rome
les passagers d'un appareil en partance
pour israël ont dû changer d'avion
dernier moment à la suite d'un coup de
fil en provenance de la police de zurich
10h39 hier à francfort cet avion
autrichien d'école pour vienne 33
passagers à bord et un sac postal pour
israël qui devaient être transférés à
bord d'un avion dès la 20 minutes plus
tard d'une bombe explose dans la soute à
bagages l'avion vole alors à 3000 m
d'altitude le pilote reçoit l'ordre de
revenir à francfort il pourra poser son
avion
pas de blessé conclusion des experts pas
de doute c'est en attente 13 ans 14 à
zurich une coronado de la swissair
d'école à son tour pour tel-aviv
six minutes plus tard le pilote signal
par radio qu'une explosion vient de se
produire à bord en quelques instants la
sonde y dégage une telle fumée que le
pilote ne voit plus son tableau de bord
il reçoit l'ordre de revenir vers zurich
trop tard l'avion s'écrase dans un bois
à quelques kilomètres de la frontière
allemande
l'appareil a été complètement détruit
pas un débris supérieure à un mètre
quarante sept personnes à bord 47 morts
parmi eux onze israéliens l'attentât
n'est pas encore certain mais la
coïncidence des deux explosions est
troublante il s'agit peut-être d'une
minuterie du même type dans les deux
dans les deux explosions
vingt minutes après le décollage
explosion à bord de l'avion autrichien
six minutes après le décollage à bord de
l'avion suisse mais il avec 15 minutes
de retard avant de partir de juristes
depuis la fin de la guerre des six jours
en 1967 le nombre des organisations de
commando palestinien a proliféré dans
l'ensemble du monde arabe
à côté des grandes organisations comme
le fatah sont nés plusieurs groupuscules
qui de temps en temps se livrent à des
opérations plus ou moins spectaculaires
c'est ainsi qu'après l'explosion du
coronado qui assurait la ligne zurich
tel aviv de beyrouth une dépêche de
l'agencé américaine à société de presse
affirmaient qu'un porte parole du
commandement général du front populaire
de libération
l'une de ces petites organisations
revendiqué cet attentat
or comme vous le disais tout à l'heure
jean paul sauter ce matin le
porte-parole de cette organisation
affirmé à l'agencé france presse
une fausse déclaration lui avaient été
attribués et que son organisation
n'étaient nullement impliqués dans cette
affaire
malgré cela les israéliens sont
persuadés que ces attentats ont été
commis par les palestiniens
l attentat de la suisse air intervenant
au moment où amman le roi hussein
négocié avec yasser arafat le leader
palestinien leader de très nombreuses
organisation de libération de la
palestine il n'est pas impossible que
s'appuyant sur l'opinion internationale
très ému par l'attentât d'hier et sur sa
droite le roi hussein ne renforce sa
propre position il s'agit pour lui de
contrôler les agissements des forces de
libération palestinienne opérant depuis
le territoire jordanien
et si entraînant de leur côté les
palestiniens et il ya ces rares afat
fort de l'appui de moscou reproche au
roi de freiner l'élan révolutionnaire et
libérateur des fedayins dans cette
affaire tout le prestige du roi hussein
est en jeu et son trône également les
entretiens se poursuivre aujourd'hui à
une extrême orient intensification des
combats dans cette zone du monde après
la prise hier par les forces communistes
de la plaine des jarres au laos
recrudescence des combats au vietnam
également voici les photos de la plaine
des jarres l'état dans lequel s
plusieurs villes se trouvent depuis ces
combats voici les forces communistes
recrudescence donc des combats au
vietnam également à la frontière du laos
et au sud de la zone démilitarisée
pendant les dernières 24 heures les b 52
américains sont intervenus quatre fois
dans cette zone nouvelles de l'europe la
grande bretagne demeure candidate au
marché commun monsieur harold wilson
premier ministre britannique l'a
réaffirmé hier soir au cours d'un
discours prononcé lors d'une réunion
travailliste cependant monsieur wilson a
précisé que la grande bretagne ne
paierait pas un prix trop élevé pour
cette entrée il répondait ainsi aux
conservateurs qui semble décidée à ne
poser aucune condition à l'entrée de la
grande bretagne dans le marché commun
cette réaffirmation de la vente de la
volonté de monsieur wilson intervient
après un récent sondage vous vous en
souvenez qui monterait à l'évidence
l'hostilité des anglais à l'égard du
marché commun il se prononçait à environ
75% contre cette entrée second grand
titre de ce journal michel fau que et
thérèse le madr sont en prison faut que
a été inculpés d'enlèvement de mineurs
de séquestration d'extorsion de fonds
thérèse le madr est accusé de complicité
elle a reconnu avoir gardé sophie
pendant les trois jours de sa
séquestration
il est un peu plus d'une heure du matin
quand michel fau que qui le palais de
justice de soissons il vient tout juste
d'apprendre que thérèse le marbre est à
son tour inculpé de complicité
interrogé toute la soirée séparément
faut que a pourtant prétendu avoir agi
seul mais thérèse le badr elle vient
d'avouer avoir gardé pendant trois jours
la petite sophie faut que va donc
retrouver la prison il va passer cette
première nuit dans une cellule de la
maison d'arrêt de soissons quelques
minutes après la sortie de faux que le
procureur chirol répond brièvement les
mares de sophie sophie dugué a été placé
sous mandat de dépôt thérèse le baht a
été inculpé de complicité dans
l'enlèvement et placé sous mandat trip
pas d'inculpation à prévoir pendant cinq
ans c'est ensuite au juge d'instruction
mademoiselle anzani de quitter le palais
de justice
elle le fait sans commentaire
mademoiselle anzani juge d'instruction
peut ainsi refermé une première partie
de son dossier mais quelques questions
restent posées faut que avait t'il
d'autres complices et pour quelle raison
at il tenu si longtemps en échec
policiers et gendarmes de soissons
claude la peau répond peut-être la
question ici la gendarmerie de soissons
michel fau coeur et thérèse le madr ont
avoué michel fau que être le ravisseur
de la petite sophie dugué thérèse le
madr avoir gardé l'enfant pendant trois
jours dans sa petite maison à bertry
mais thérèse et michel n'ont pas été
confrontés cette nuit pour seul horizon
maintenant les murs priest de leur
cellule et pourtant ils avaient pâti
bâti passionnant depuis quatre mois un
univers tout en rose mais non sans
risque c'était pensait-il le début d'une
belle aventure l'avenir assuré pour eux
et leurs trois enfants
et tout cela d'un seul coup s'est
écroulé michel fau qu' il faut le dire
n'est pas un gangster ce n'est pas un
malfrat c'est un petit voleur de voiture
sans envergure jamais il ne m'arrêteront
avait dit michel foucault et il le
croyait et il a fallu justement cette
affaire duguay pour que faut que se
découvre lui-même je le sais car j'ai
reçu ses confidences par personne
interposée
il ya deux mois c'était en décembre
dernier quelques jours après la folle
nuit de noël souvenez-vous qui avait
mobilisé toutes les polices de france
aujourd'hui je peux le dire j'avais
rendez vous avec michel fau que dans les
bois de walincourt entre cambrai et
caudry dans une petite cabane
désaffectée d'un garde-forestier il
avait accepté michel de tout nous
raconter avant qu'ils ne passent la
frontière franco espagnole
là ils devaient être prises en charge
par une bande de trafiquants qui lui
avait trouvé une planque
mais est-il dans une maison close
ensuite eh bien c'était la grande
aventure et il avait son programme mais
voilà voilà pour réaliser ses projets
michel foucault il faut le dire était
tributaire d'un troisième personnage
dont il n'a pas été question jusqu'à
présent dans l'instruction son affaire
et qui j'en suis persuadé l'autre
conflit
donc il a donné le nom hier mais ce nom
n'a pas été prononcé c'est le 21
décembre 1969 il ya donc deux mois que
michel foucault se manifeste pour la
première fois depuis le rapt de la
petite sophie du qe 2 mois déjà que
toutes les polices de france le
recherche il est insaisissable
c'est le suspect numéro un et ce jour là
il se confesse il dit le ravisseur c'est
moi j'ai agi seul j'ai emmené la petite
sophie chez moi à bertry et c'est
thérèse qui l'a gardé trois jours jamais
je n'ai quitté mais repris sauf pour
quelques petites expéditions nocturnes
je vis caché dans le coffrage de la
baignoire que j'ai moi même aménagé et
j'étais là quand les policiers sont
venus à deux reprises perquisitionné à
la maison et quand il m'arrive de
rentrer chez moi à la maison la nuit et
bien j'aperçois les gendarmes
c'est simple je passe tout simplement
par les tours voilà ce que disait faut
que le troisième personnage de cette
affaire dont je faisais et allié un
instant ne se manifeste pas contacté
pour plusieurs fois il refuse de se
compromettre
c'est lui qui possède le contact avec
valence là où il doit échanger les
billets de la rançon contre de la bonne
monnaie courante 50% ça c'est la règle
du milieu c'est lui aussi qui paissaient
de la filière pour le passage en espagne
pour l'instant tout est bloqué faut que
s'inquiète et s'énerve d'autres
confidences l'apprendront qu'un truand
chevronné un homme du milieu très connu
qui à table ouverte dans le monde
interlope des trafiquants internationaux
a proposé à michel fau que de l'aider
dans le trafic d armes bio fera au
biafra et sinon dans celui de la drogue
c'était cela la belle aventure dont
rêvait michel fauquier thérèse le marbre
qui la première des rays le madr on peut
le révéler aujourd'hui eu l'idée du rapt
de la petite sophie dugué
l'horaire aujourd'hui s'est transformé
en cauchemar vous le voyez le prix nos
pépins nouvelles de france
a la sncf la situation est normale les
cheminots d'avignon ayant décidé de
reprendre le travail demain les
syndicats à l'exception de la cgt
signeront l'accord intervenu vendredi
entre la direction de la sncf et les
syndicats ce propos je vais vous donner
lecture d'une déclaration de monsieur
bergeron secrétaire général de force
ouvrière
il a déclaré ce matin lorsque les
dirigeants de la fédération des
cheminots cgt affirme n'avoir pas donné
de mot d'ordre de grève
ils nous prennent pour des naïfs nous ne
croyons pas à la génération spontanée
or les faits ont montré à travers
l'accord concernant les petites
catégories de la fonction publique lors
de l'accord conclu à l'électricité et au
gaz de france et avec ce qui vient de se
passer à la sncf que la cgt ne peut rien
empêcher lorsque le mouvement syndical
libre et déterminé nous parlons sport
maintenant avec que patrick chapuis les
français ont remporté de nouveaux succès
en ski mais cette fois ça se passait de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
jackson hole c'est aux états unis là bas
les montagnards portent des chapeaux de
cow boy et c'est là bas qu isabelle me a
remporté sa troisième grande descente de
la saison
elle n'aura manqué finalement que celle
de val gardena cinq françaises prennent
les cinq premières places dans l'ordre
isabelle mir ali famose michel jacquot
florence traire et françoise maquis en
coupe du monde michel jacquot en porsche
renforce sa place en tête du classement
chez les hommes la coupe du monde domine
également la suite des épreuves puisque
l'autrichien karl schranz
le suisse toni et les français pâtit le
français patrick russel ne sont séparés
que par deux points dans la descente
remportée hier par karl coordin 46e et
patrick russel 18e n'ont pas marqué le
moindre point dans le slalom
bruxelles peut distancie chance d'autant
plus qu'elle est français jean noël
augert peines ébréché obligeront chante
à prendre des risques
sport d'équipé maintenant l'actualité
est également très favorable aux
français puisque en basket la france a
effacé son match nul de vendredi en
battant la hollande 81 62 victoires
également de la france en bol 13 à 11
pour palais des sports de nanterre en
football
à lisbonne l'équipe de france junior et
le portugal ont fait match nul 0 à 0
ici le français carrier balle au pied
temps de tromper le gardien portugais
matos tennis pour finir le roumain
nastase s'est qualifié pour la finale du
tournoi open des états unis en battant
l'anglais taylor la finale opposera la
stase à l'amérique akli fritsch bien
patrick chapuis je pense que nous aurons
plus de détails au cours de télé
dimanche et surtout ce soir un score
dimanche à l'intendant je vous souhaite
un excellent après-midi à plus tard
m